Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个目前正在进行的正让人兴奋的事情。如果你曾好奇如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是一个有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自一个完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Today we are thinking about what a viva is when it comes to psychology and how you can prepare optimally for yours or support somebody who might need to do the same for theirs. Stay
这些原则都同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将亲自送出极棒的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的链接树（Linktree）Dr Marianne Trent，或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个快速私信，我会把所有细节发给你。好啦，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天我们要探讨的是心理学中的“论文答辩（viva）”是什么，以及你该如何为自己的答辩做好最佳准备，或者如何支持需要为自己的答辩做准备的人。请留
right to the end because we've got so many tips to get through. Hope you find it so useful. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm able to say that to you because I am a doctor and because I got that doctorate by doing the thesis part of my training. If I hadn't passed my viva and my research components, I would not be a doctor. And so that is why it's super important to make sure that we're
在节目最后，因为我们有超多的实用小贴士要分享。希望你会觉得它非常有用。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让它成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这里是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是主持人玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我之所以能对你这么说，是因为我是一名博士，而且我是通过完成培训中的论文部分才获得这个博士学位的。如果我没有通过论文答辩和研究部分，我就成不了博士。因此，这就是为什么确保我们
supporting you optimally to know what vas are and how to blast yours out of the park with any luck. So first and foremost, what is a viva? And you might be like, a what now? Let me tell you how you spell that in case it's not a term that you've heard before. It's V-I-V-A. If you can think back to any French or German or Spanish exams that you might have done, perhaps for your GCSEs, there might well have been an oral component to that. I certainly had a French GCSE oral, which didn't go hugely well, but that is in essence a bit of a viva. It's a spoken examination where you talk about your knowledge of a subject. The knowledge in question for this viva that we're talking about will either be
以最佳方式支持你了解什么是答辩，并希望你能顺利通过它，是超级重要的。首先也是最重要的是，什么是答辩？你可能会想：“什么东西？”让我告诉你它的拼写，以防这不是你以前听过的一个词。它是V-I-V-A（Viva）。如果你能回想一下你可能做过的任何法语、德语或西班牙语考试，也许是为了你的GCSE（英国中等教育普通证书），其中很可能会有一个口语部分。我当年的GCSE法语口语考得确实不太好，但本质上，这就有点像答辩。它是一个口试，你需要谈论你对某个学科的知识。我们今天讨论的这个答辩中所涉及的知识，要么是
your undergraduate dissertation, your master's thesis, or your doctoral or PhD thesis. And this viva will give you the opportunity to defend your work and to explain it it assists the examiners who will be on your panel to understand and to truly recognize that you are competent and proficient and that your research is going to be sound and robust it also allows them to check that you are meeting the requirements for the qualification being awarded. So it does feel like kind of a big deal because it is. It's really the final hurdle for any of your qualifications. Not all undergraduate courses offer vivas. Certainly I didn't have a viva for my dissertation but I know that some undergraduate universities do ask their students to sit vivas.
你的本科毕业论文、硕士学位论文，还是你的博士学位论文（Doctoral or PhD thesis）。这个答辩将为你提供一个捍卫你的工作并对其进行解释的机会。它有助于评审委员会的考官们理解并真正认识到你是称职且精通的，你的研究将是合理且扎实的。它还允许他们检查你是否符合所授予资格的要求。所以这感觉像是一件大事，因为它的确是。这确实是你任何资格认证的最后一道坎。并非所有的本科课程都提供答辩。当然，我的本科毕业论文没有答辩，但我知道有些本科院校确实要求学生参加答辩。
So firstly we're going to talk a bit more about what a viva is, what it might look like and then I'm going to guide you through pretty much about 12 top tips for areas to consider. So a viva is usually conducted at your university or remotely perhaps if you have been doing an online program of study it will usually consist of somebody from your course who hasn't been involved in your research it wouldn't be appropriate or ethical for your own research supervisor to do your viva but there will also be an external person on the panel at least one more than one, but certainly in my viva, it was one person from the course and one person externally who comes in and holds you to account and holds the standards. And that was in a two to one meeting. And it was scary, you know, it felt like
所以首先，我们要多谈谈什么是答辩，它可能是什么样的，然后我将带你了解大约12个需要考虑的核心技巧。因此，答辩通常在你的大学举行，或者如果你一直在进行在线学习项目，也可能是远程进行。它通常由你课程中的某个人组成，这个人没有参与你的研究——你的研究导师来做你的答辩人是不恰当也不道德的。但评审团中还会有一位外部人员，至少有一位，甚至不止一位。但在我的答辩中，是一个人来自本校课程，另一个人是外部聘请来把关和维持标准的外部人员。那是一场二对一的会议。这很吓人，你知道的，感觉
kind of a big deal, but I don't really think I realized what a big deal it might be because I thought it was all going to be breezy I thought it was all going to be fine and I might guide you through that as I talk about my top tips so let's plow on with top tip number one so tip number one is understanding the format. So this can be really useful for you to know how long it's expected to last. And it might be how long is a piece of string? Because if it goes really well, you might be in and out, you know, or if you get a little bit hauled over the coals, it might well be longer than expected. But is there in your university or place of study is there a maximum length or a minimum length that you're kept for asking those questions can be really useful who
像是一件大事，但我当时真的没有意识到它会有多大，因为我以为一切都会轻而易举，我以为一切都会顺顺利利。当我谈到我的顶级技巧时，我可能会带你回顾一下这段经历。所以让我们直接切入技巧一。技巧一是了解形式。了解预期持续多长时间，这会对你非常有用。这可能就像“绳子有多长”一样难以预测，因为如果进展顺利，你可能很快就能进出；或者如果你被稍微盘问了一番，时间可能比预期的要长。但是，在你的大学或学习地点，是否有规定你必须留在那里的最高时长或最低时长？询问这些问题会非常有用。
is going to be doing your viva that's part of understanding the format so i knew in advance who was going to be doing my viva and this was then my opportunity to google those people and the research that they had done to get a feel for what their own particular preference for methodology might be and for how rigorous and robust they might be too. I didn't want any surprises, it also gave me the chance to work out what they're going to look like because I googled them so at least it just brings down those levels of anxiety a little bit. As part of understanding the format it can be really useful for you to know what the assessment criteria are. So what are those benchmarks that you're trying to measure up against?
谁将负责你的答辩？这也是了解形式的一部分。所以我提前知道了谁会负责我的答辩，这成了我谷歌搜索这些人及他们所做研究的机会，以便对他们特定的方法论偏好以及他们可能有多严格和严谨有一个大致的了解。我不想有任何惊喜，这也让我有机会通过谷歌搜索他们，弄清楚他们长什么样，从而稍微缓解了一点焦虑水平。作为了解形式的一部分，了解评估标准也会非常有用。那么，你试图与之对标的基准是什么？
So knowing where you will and perhaps won't score points can be really useful to make sure that you're covering those points if and when required. So top tip number two is reviewing your research. I know it can feel a bit boring and it can feel like you are totally up to the hilt with where you're at with your research but you're going to need to make time to read it in its entirety and to almost treat it as if it's not your baby and to treat it with a critical inquiring mind if you can. If this was the first time you'd seen this piece of work what would you be thinking about it? If you've used any particular approaches and you've used any kind of manuals or particular models for the approaches that you've used then it might well be helpful to revisit those books or that
所以，知道你在哪里会得分，或者在哪里可能不会得分，对于确保你在需要时能够涵盖这些要点会非常有用。因此，技巧二是复习你的研究。我知道这感觉有点枯燥，而且你可能会觉得你对研究的进展已经了如指掌，但你需要腾出时间完整地阅读它，并且尽可能地把它当成不是你自己的“亲生孩子”，而是用批判性、探究性的思维来对待它。如果这是你第一次看到这件作品，你会怎么想？如果你使用过任何特定方法，并查阅了任何手册或特定模型，那么重新温习这些书籍或
guidance so that you are up to speed with what the gold standard would be and how yours might deviate outside of that. That was a little bit of a learning point for me, I have to say. So I was doing grounded theory and was using a particular type of grounded theory from a particular book, but hadn't ever quite got around to reading the book in its entirety, don't do that. Don't do that. Learn from me. Read all of the books that you say that you've read. Don't just skim read, because it might well come back and bite you in the bum. So you need to be in a position where you know your own work, where you know what you've said, and where you are able to defend your own methodology. You might need to
指南可能会有所帮助，这样你就能了解黄金标准是什么，以及你的研究是如何偏离这些标准的。说实话，这对我来说是一个小小的学习点。当时我正在做扎根理论（grounded theory），并使用来自某本书的特定类型的扎根理论，但我从来没有完全通读过整本书。千万别这样做！别学我。读完你声称自己读过的所有书。不要只进行略读，因为这可能会在以后反咬你一口。因此，你需要处于这样一种状态：你了解自己的工作，知道自己说过的话，并且能够捍卫自己的方法论。你可能需要
explain in more detail why you did certain things, why you didn't do certain things, what happened in case it's not clear. And we don't want any apprentice style interview blips or Dragon's Den brain farts where you're like, oh, I don't know. I can't remember. So going through your own research timeline, how it's been, what you did, what the stumbling blocks were and reading the stuff that you've submitted can be so important. You should know this inside and out. You are the expert on this and you need to demonstrate that. So top tip number three, when you're doing your prep, you need to perhaps be thinking about anticipating any questions that you might be asked. Might be useful to think about the strengths and weaknesses for your work and maybe to think about trying to record yourself talking out loud about some of those as if answering those questions. This can really help in easing your comfortability curve with hearing your own voice
更详细地解释你为什么做了某些事，为什么没有做某些事，如果不清楚的话，当时发生了什么。我们不希望出现任何《学徒》（Apprentice）风格的面试失误，或者《创智赢家》（Dragon's Den）式的脑回路短路，让你觉得：“哦，我不知道，我不记得了。”因此，梳理你自己的研究时间线、它是如何进展的、你做了什么、绊脚石是什么，以及阅读你提交的东西，是如此重要。你应该对这一切了如指掌。你是这方面的专家，你需要证明这一点。因此，技巧三，当你在做准备时，你需要考虑预测你可能会被问到的任何问题。
and hearing yourself talk about you and your work and treating yourself as credible and important and worthwhile of course. If you're working in a placement or you've got some other form of paid work it might be a really nice opportunity to ask if you can present at a work meeting so that you can about your research so that you can get used to talking about it and then answering any questions that they might field to you. Encourage them to do so because that's really, really useful experience and stuff that you just might not see coming. It's better to have that among your colleagues rather than have it in the viva. Nobody likes to be blindsided. Okay, top tip number four. You're going to need to go back to the literature. I'm sorry, I'm sorry. You're going to need to have
思考你工作的优势和劣势可能会很有用，也许可以考虑将自己大声回答其中一些问题的过程录音。这真的有助于缓解你听到自己声音的尴尬感，
a look at the literature that you've included in your literature review and in your introduction. You're going to need to see if there's any new research that might have come up since you last did that. You're going to have to have a look at how your research fits into the broader picture of what's out there or what's come out there since. How have you helped to advance this knowledge base? Top tip number five is thinking about concise summaries. And for this, you might find it useful to listen to or watch episode 65 of the podcast, how to learn and revise better for exams or interviews. So in terms of the summaries for what you're going to need to think about, It can be really useful to summarise your key areas. So for example, methodology, findings, conclusions into concise bullet points that you are then able to talk about freely and that are free for you to be able to draw upon when you need to.
听自己谈论自己和你的工作，并把你自己视为一个可信的、重要的、当然也是有价值的人。如果你正在实习或者有其他形式的有薪工作，这可能是一个非常好的机会，可以询问是否能够在工作会议上做一个关于你研究的展示，这样你就可以习惯谈论它，然后回答他们可能向你抛出的任何问题。鼓励他们这样做，因为这是非常、非常有用的经验，能让你见识到你可能意料不到的事情。最好是在你的同事中间经历这些，而不是在答辩时才遇到。没有人喜欢被打个措手不及。好吧，技巧四。你需要回到文献中去。对不起，对不起！你需要去
This is why I refer you to the episode 65 because there are some limitations to summarising. So do check out that at the end and I'll put a link for that at the end of this episode. So let's take a quick break here and I'll be back along with loads more tips that you're not going to want to miss out on. If you do find this content helpful, please do rate it and review it if you are listening on Spotify or Apple. And if you're watching on YouTube, please do like, subscribe and comment. Donations or tip for the content that I create for you is so gratefully received and there is information in the show notes or in the description below if you want to check that out. I'll be back along very soon. See you soon. I'll be back along very soon. I'll see you on the other side. Become a psychologist and let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
看看你包含在文献综述（literature review）和引言中的文献。你需要看看自从你上次这样做以来，是否有任何新的研究出现。你必须看看你的研究如何融入到现有的大局中，或者自那以后出现了什么新成果。你是如何帮助推进这个知识库的？技巧五是思考简洁的总结。为此，你可能会发现收听或观看播客第65集很有用——《如何更好地学习和复习考试或面试》。因此，就你需要考虑的总结而言，
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back along. Thank you for listening this far. I hope you'll find the rest of this really useful too. So top tip number six is practicing your presentation skills. This is where you're going to have to get your webcam out, sit, look at yourself, practice eye contact with people, practice, you know, talking to people, hearing your voice out loud loud looking at your body language when you talk about your research you know we want nice open um you know perhaps some gestures we don't want not to and like if
把你的关键领域（例如方法论、发现、结论）总结成简洁的要点，然后你就可以自由地谈论它们，并在需要时能够自如地提取，这会非常有用。
you're hating the research area we don't want that to flow out of you as you're talking about it practice perhaps sitting with your hands in a loose, unclenched position to really encourage all the good hormones to flow, not the stress ones as much as possible. You might want to talk at yourself in a mirror as well. As you're about to brush your teeth or maybe even as you're brushing your teeth, talk to yourself. Talk yourself through your research at regular opportunities. Practice, practice, practice, hopefully makes perfect. And speaking of practice, number seven is thinking about whether you can arrange a mock viva. This might be with your actual research supervisor, either clinical or academic, or maybe both.
这就是为什么我让你参考第65集，因为总结是有一定局限性的。所以在最后去看看那一集吧，我会在本集末尾放一个链接。那么我们在这里稍作休息，我马上回来，并会带来大量你绝对不想错过的精彩技巧。如果你确实觉得这些内容很有帮助，如果你正在使用Spotify或Apple收听，请给它评分和评论。如果你在YouTube上观看，请点赞、订阅并评论。非常感谢大家对我和我为你创作的内容的打赏或小费，如果你想查看相关信息，节目文稿或下方的描述中都有提供。我很快就会回来。回头见。我很快就会回来。我们另一端见。成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。充满了课程和经验，将帮助你获得资格。
This will help familiarise you with the process of Aviva and maybe, you know, strengthen some of those Achilles heels if you feel there are some. This is a chance for people who might already be familiar with your research and your work to grill you and to compassionately support you in this process, which can feel quite anxiety provoking at times. Top tip number eight is to really think about the weaknesses for your research. None of us are perfect people. And as a result, we don't create and produce perfect research. And that has to be okay. We do the best that we can. But there's always things that could be improved or, you know, might be better in an ideal world. So if we think about what the gold standard might have been, in terms of your recruitment size, in terms of the methodology,
所以快来看看吧。就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。欢迎回来。谢谢你收听了这么久。希望你也会觉得剩下的内容同样非常有用。所以技巧六是练习你的演讲技巧。在这里，你需要拿出网络摄像头，坐下来，看着自己，练习与人们的眼神交流，练习，你知道的，与人们交谈，大声听到自己的声音，在谈论你的研究时观察自己的肢体语言，你知道的，我们希望有很好的开放性，嗯，你知道的，也许有一些手势，我们不希望，比如
in terms of the quality of the stuff you were able to get out of your research, think about those as weaknesses, but things that, you know, you might well be asked. Think about how you'd respond constructively to any criticism or weaknesses that are identified that you may or may not have considered. Being wounded and hurt and gutted and devastated and hostile in your defence of this, as if it is actually one of your children who's been criticized is probably not going to be super helpful. So just allowing people to go through this process with you because it's their job to do it and because in order to get your qualification it's part of the process you need to be prepared for the fact that they might not love what you've done. They may feel that it could have been done
如果你讨厌这个研究领域，我们不希望当你在谈论它时，这种情绪从你身上流露出来。练习把双手放在放松、不紧握的姿势，真正鼓励所有积极的荷尔蒙流动，尽可能减少压力荷尔蒙。你可能也想在镜子里对着自己说话。当你正要刷牙时，或者甚至在刷牙时，对自己说话。在规律的时刻对自己讲述你的研究。练习，练习，再练习，希望熟能生巧。说到练习，技巧七是考虑是否可以安排一次模拟答辩。
better. Top tip number nine is staying up to date. So could you read some new books or publications? Could you broaden your understanding of this area to make sure that you've got things to be able to draw upon and reference if the time comes for it at your viva. What are the hot themes and debates in this area at the moment? Who are the movers and the shakers? You know, what research are they doing that might not be exactly similar, but might have some overlap with yours? So now we are on to the top tips about the day. It's happening. It's here. You know, you've lost all the sleep you're going to lose over this, hopefully. Today is the day of your viva. We're going to be looking at top tip number 10, being aiming to stay calm and confident.
这可以与你真正的研究导师进行，无论是临床的还是学术的，或者两者兼而有之。这有助于让你熟悉答辩的过程，也许还能（你知道的）加强那些你觉得有些薄弱的“阿喀琉斯之踵”。这是一个让那些可能已经熟悉你的研究和工作的人来“严加拷问”你的机会，同时也在这个有时会引起高度焦虑的过程中给予你富有同情心的支持。技巧八是真正思考你研究的弱点。我们都不是完美的人。因此，我们也不会创造和产出完美的研冷。这必须是可以接受的。我们尽了最大的努力。但总有一些地方可以改进，或者说，（你知道的）在理想世界中可能会更好。
Deep breaths, you know, positive mindset, imagining that it's going to go well. You know, you can practice that eventuality as well. It should hopefully feel like the people on your panel are there to hold you to rigor, but not rip you to shreds. The aim is that this is a scholarly discussion about your work, not hopefully to be really sneaky and try and catch you off guard. So you can go in there and allow yourself to just do your best, you know, try and stay within your window of tolerance, try and think about the way you're sitting. So we want to be sitting with an open posture, not like this with our shoulders really hunched forward, because that might tell the body that we are in fight and flight mode. And we want to be letting the adrenaline flow to help aid our
如果我们考虑一下黄金标准会是什么样，从你的招募规模来看，从方法论来看，
performance. But we don't want to go so fast and furious with that adrenaline and the cortisol that our performance is affected negatively. Top tip number 11 is that it's okay to ask for clarification. If things are phrased in a weird way or you are tipping outside of your window of tolerance, don't be afraid to ask for the question again or to ask for a little bit of clarification to help your understanding of what the question is. Take some breaths, just take a moment. If you know that you find it helpful, then maybe consider taking a notepad with you. It's better to check rather than kind of ramble or waffle on and give something that just isn't super useful to what you're talking about, because that's not going to help you shine. And last but not least, just be thoughtful, honest,
从你能从研究中获得的东西的质量来看，把这些当作弱点，但它们（你知道的）很可能是你会被问到的问题。思考你将如何建设性地回应任何被指出的、你可能考虑过也可能没有考虑过的批评或弱点。带着创伤、痛苦、心碎、毁灭感以及敌意来为自己辩护，就好像这真的是你的某个被批评的孩子一样，可能不会有什么帮助。所以，只是允许人们陪你经历这个过程，因为这是他们的工作，而且为了获得资格证书，这是流程的一部分，你需要做好心理准备，他们可能不会喜欢你所做的一切。他们可能会觉得这本可以做得
interested and polite. If you don't know the answer to something, it's OK to say that. And sometimes with clients still now, I'm like, I'm not quite sure, but I'll make sure that I make a note to try and find that out for you. Or just, you know, that is a really interesting point. I hadn't considered that. I'm not actually sure of the answer. But this is maybe how I would go about you know finding that answer. So maybe I'd look at the literature base, maybe I'd look at the evidence base, maybe I'd consider what books might be around there or maybe I'd contact an expert in
更好。技巧九是保持最新状态。那么，你能阅读一些新书或出版物吗？你能拓宽对这个领域的理解，以确保当答辩时时机到来时，你有东西可以提取和引用吗？目前这个领域的热门主题和辩论是什么？谁是推动者和撼动者？（你知道的）他们在做什么研究，可能不完全相似，但可能与你的研究有一些重叠？现在我们进入关于“当天”的顶级技巧。它要发生了。它就在这里。你知道的，你为了这件事已经失眠够了，希望如此。今天就是你答辩的日子。我们将着眼于技巧十：争取保持冷静和自信。
the field to help illuminate my understanding of this and to see where there might be some overlap between my work and theirs. You could offer alternative perspectives if you're not quite sure of that answer. Just think around the problem, but be honest. You know, we don't expect you to know everything. This is, you know, definitely not a perfectionist approach that we're striving for. So yeah, remembering that the viva is supposed to be an opportunity to showcase you and your brilliant work rather than feeling like you're being hauled over the coals and ripped to shreds can be really key too. Some people really enjoy their viva from start to finish because it's talking about an area that they are passionate and proud of and I hope that you will absolutely be in that camp. I really enjoyed the first and the third paper section of my viva. Did not enjoy
深呼吸，（你知道的）积极的心态，想象它会进展顺利。你知道的，你也可以练习那种最终的结果。希望你的评审团成员会让你觉得，他们是在那里要求你保持严谨，而不是要把你撕成碎片。其目的是，这是一场关于你的工作的学术讨论，而不是（希望如此）真的鬼鬼祟祟地试图让你措手不及。所以你可以走进去，让自己尽力而为，（你知道的）尽量保持在你的容纳窗（window of tolerance）内，思考你的坐姿。所以我们要以开放的姿势坐着，不要像这样把肩膀向前耸起，因为这可能会告诉身体我们处于战斗或逃跑模式。我们希望肾上腺素流动来帮助提升我们的
the second bit, the middle bit. With proper preparation and what is it they say, prior planning prevents poor performance. And we don't want poor performance for you. So I hope you found my whistle-stop tour through my 12 top tips for preparing for and understanding what your viva will be really useful if you did find it helpful please do rate and review the podcast and like subscribe and comment if watching on youtube if you think someone else might find this content useful please do share it with them sharing really is caring thank you so much for being part of my world. If you've got ideas for future podcast episodes, please do let me know. Otherwise, stay kind to
表现。但我们不希望肾上腺素和皮质醇走得太快、太猛烈，以至于我们的表现受到负面影响。技巧十一是：请求澄清是可以的。如果事情的表述很奇怪，或者你超出了容纳窗，不要害怕再次询问问题，或者要求做一点澄清，以帮助你理解问题是什么。做几次深呼吸，花点时间。如果你知道记笔记对你有帮助，那么可以考虑随身带一个记事本。核实一下总比信口开河、胡言乱语，或者给出一个对你正在谈论的内容超级没有帮助的回答要好，因为那不会让你大放异彩。最后但并非最不重要的一点是，要体贴、诚实、
yourself and I'll catch up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be with you from 6am on Monday. Take care. Bye. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psych well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
感兴趣且有礼貌。如果你不知道某事的答案，说出来是没问题的。有时对来访者来说，直到现在我还会说：“我不太确定，但我一定会记下来，设法为你找出答案。”或者只是，（你知道的）“那真是一个非常有趣的点。我以前没考虑过。我其实不太确定答案。但这也许是我会如何去（你知道的）寻找答案的方式。”所以也许我会查阅文献库，也许我会查阅证据库，也许我会考虑周围可能会有哪些书，或者也许我会联系一个领域的专家
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来帮助阐明我对这一点的理解，并看看我的工作和他们的工作之间可能在哪里有一些重叠。如果你不太确定答案，你可以提供替代视角。只要围绕问题思考，但要诚实。你知道的，我们并不期望你无所不知。这（你知道的）绝对不是我们所追求的完美主义方法。所以，记住答辩应该是一个展示你和你出色工作的机会，而不是感觉自己被严加拷问并被撕成碎片，这也是非常关键的。有些人从头到尾真的很享受他们的答辩，因为这是在谈论一个他们充满激情和自豪的领域，我希望你绝对能属于那个阵营。我真的很享受我的答辩的第一部分和第三部分。一点都不喜欢